en la habitación de baran nuri quedaron
estas fotografías como recuerdo con su
prometido esta iraquí de 24 años quería
viajar al reino unido para verse con él
atravesando el canal de la mancha en un
bote según su familia la mujer hace
parte del grupo de migrantes que
murieron ahogados esta semana
william hague
sentía algo en mi corazón no pude dormir
durante dos noches antes del incidente
sentí lo mismo cuando mi padre falleció
dije eso es todo
balance ha ido para rusia pero la muerte
de baran aún no ha sido confirmada
oficialmente las autoridades francesas
guardan silencio por el momento fue el
novio de la mujer quien se comunicó con
su familia en el kurdistán iraquí
todos están inconsolables la joven logró
obtener una visa para ir a europa y
luego intento de entrar en varias
ocasiones a reino unido de manera legal
al ver que no lo lograba decidió pagarle
a un traficante quien le vendió un
puesto en uno de los barcos con
migrantes
ella nunca le contó a su familia ni a su
padre no los quería angustiar
mi hija se comprometió y se casó ahora
su esposo está en reino unido
ambos estaban tratando de construir una
vida mejor pero eso se terminó
era el destino de dios se ahogó en el
mar y falleció antes de llegar hasta
allá
el padre de la mujer hizo un llamado a
todos aquellos que arriesgan su vida
viajando en los botes que salen
diferencia al reino unido para que dejen
de sacrificar sus vidas